hey everyone I'm Abbey sharp welcome to
Abbey's kitchen as you can surely guess
we are practicing serious social
distancing up here in Canada my family's
being pretty conservative and we're
completely isolating despite being
healthy and well. It's really scary times
for all of us and I know we're all
juggling a lot but I want you to know
that I'm going to try to the best of my
ability
to continue with my usual posting
schedule to give you all some
much-needed entertainment and education.
Having said that please keep in mind
that my videographer is obviously no
longer with me so I'm having to try to
navigate this whole thing on my own
which is a skill that I honestly don't
really have so please bear with me as I
stumble through this and maybe the
quality is not as good as usual but I'm
just going to try to do my best and hope
that it's relatively watchable for you
guys. Now today I wanted to discuss in
detail the risks and safety of different
modes of getting your family food. Now
there's been a lot of questions on my
feed about grocery shopping versus
delivery versus takeout during this
coronavirus outbreak and I really want
to talk about how ultimately to keep
yourself fed safe and still sane. So we
dove into the actual research and the
official recommendations to help you
determine the safest way to get food
into your house. Now as always my general
disclaimer that the information in this
video is for education and entertainment
purposes only and is not in any way
intended to prescribe or diagnose so
please always reach out and speak to a
health care professional about your
unique situation. Also considering the
evidence is changing literally daily in
this situation, I did want to flag that
I'm doing my best to bring you
up-to-date information but by the time
that this gets up or by the time that
you watch it things may change. So always
keep an eye on the CDC and other health
authorities for the most up-to-date
recommendations. Okay so first things
first let's get into this. I wanted to
cover the question can COVID 19 be
transmitted through food?
Now given the rapid spread
coronavirus worldwide there's no
surprise that there's been mounting
concerns about potentially ingesting
food that has come in contact with COVID19. However, according to multiple
health and safety organizations around
the globe, including Health Canada the
Center for Disease Control and
Prevention, the European Food Safety
Authority, and the US Department of
Agriculture, there is currently no
evidence to suggest that food is a
likely route of transmission for COVID 19.
Now even though we don't know this for
sure,
as the evidence COVID 19 continues to
develop every single day, the latest
research suggests that COVID 19 does not
typically fit models of foodborne
outbreaks. According to the FDA,
a virus can only be classified as
foodborne when two or more people get
the same illness from the same
contaminated food or drink. As of this
date, there has not been a single positive
case of the virus that has been linked
specifically to food. In fact, a study
done in Singapore investigated a group
of individuals with confirmed cases of
COVID 19 to assess possible modes of
transmission. Through an extensive
interview process, the study found that
all cases could be traced back to local
transmission through clusters of people
including a tour group, a conference, and
a church gathering. None from
contaminated food. There were some early
reports that suggested that even if you
did ingest the virus through
contaminated food,
stomach acid should efficiently and
effectively inactivate the virus. However,
it appears that this may not be true as
early research has shown that some cases
of COVID 19 present with digestive
symptoms like diarrhea and a lack of
appetite, leading us to believe that the
virus may have some effect on the
gastrointestinal tract. However, like I
said, research in this area is very
limited and further studies on the
effects of COVID 19 on the digestive
system is definitely necessary before we
can make any kind of further claims. Now
even though there is limited data on how
long coronavirus can last on food, what
we do know is that the virus remains
more stable on non-porous surfaces like
metals and plastics and breaks down
faster on organic surfaces
like cardboard and food. It's also
important to consider that we all eat
multiple times in a day and if there was
a really strong link between food and
the coronavirus transmission, it would
likely have been detected by now. But
what about food packaging? Now even
though there is currently no evidence to
suggest that food packaging is
associated with the transmission of COVID
19, food packages could potentially
carry the virus if it has come in
contact with an infected person. Having
said that, experts suggest that the risk
of transmission is still relatively low
compared with other exposure routes like
person-to-person contact, which is far
more likely. You are actually way more
likely to become infected when
interacting with a worker handling the
food than from the food or food
packaging itself. Now according to the
latest research the coronavirus is able
to remain viable for hours and up to
several days on some surfaces including
copper for up to four hours, cardboard
for up to 24 hours, stainless steel for
up to three days, and plastic for up to
three days. This means that if a delivery
person or package handler infected with
COVID 19 were to cough or sneeze on a
plastic takeout package the virus could,
in theory, be able to stay on the package
for several days afterwards. Now before
we get into what to do about these risks,
I want to talk about what that means for
you in the grocery store getting takeout
or ordering delivery. Now let's start
with grocery shopping. In the store, the
truth is, if you're regularly grocery
shopping in a busy store there is some
risk there. The biggest risk is that you
may be exposed to large crowds of people
who may be infected with the virus even
though they may not be showing any signs
and they feel healthy. It's also possible
that an infected person may end up
coughing or sneezing on grocery carts,
food items, or in checkout lines which
again can increase your risk. But we all
need to eat and most people do not have
a stockpile of food in their home to
last them the weeks or potentially
months that this thing is going to last
so if you are the designated shopper in
the house, here are some tips to help
reduce your risk.
Number one, go to the grocery store as
infrequently as you can manage. Plan your
meals so that you know exactly what you're
going to need for at least a full week
so that you don't have to return to the
store several times. I know that this can
be really hard for us and, as the
nutritional gatekeeper in my home, this
has actually being particularly stressful
for me. But I have been setting aside
like a half day every Sunday for this
specific job to come up with really
simple recipes for all the meals of the
day and a thorough list of what is
needed for each. Number two, go to the
grocery store at off-peak times and
avoid crowds. So that means going really
early in the morning or really late at
night. Number three, bring gloves,
disinfectant wipes and or hand sanitizer
with you that way you can wipe down the
cart handle with a disinfectant wipe,
wear gloves for anything that you might
touch like a keypad or door handle, and
apply hand sanitizer immediately after
leaving the store. It might seem like
overkill yes but it doesn't take that
much energy to just take these extra
little precautions. Number four, minimize
contact with grocery items by following
the "you touch it you buy it" rule which
basically means no squeezing and
sampling grapes to make sure that
they're firm. Number five, avoid touching
your face, mouth, eyes and nose which I
find is easier to remember when you're
wearing gloves.
Number six, keep a distance of at least
six feet apart from the people around
you and while waiting in line. Some
stores have actually begun to ensure
that shoppers stay six feet apart by
making these measurements on the ground.
Number seven, if available use self
checkout to reduce contact with other
people. I would say of course be mindful
of touchscreen displays and barcode
scanners and be sure to sanitize your
hands after each use or wear disposable
gloves that you can throw out
immediately upon leaving the store.
Number eight, bring your own reusable
grocery bags and bag your own groceries
instead of having them handled by
another person. Number nine, avoid using
cash and use tab transactions if
possible. Number 10, wash your hands
thoroughly as soon as you get home. 11
use packaged disinfectant strategies and
take safe food preparation precautions
which I'm going to talk more about
momentarily. And 12, most importantly do
not go to the grocery store if you're
showing any symptoms of COVID 19 or
suspect that you've been exposed in some
way to the virus.
Now what about grocery delivery or
grocery pickup options? So if you do not
feel comfortable going to the grocery
store or you maybe are already sick and
100% need to be staying home, you may
have access to online grocery delivery
services in your area or you may also be
able to request to have your groceries
picked up directly from the store. The
downside of this is that a lot of people
right now are finding that these grocery
delivery apps and pickup apps are
severely backed up so if you don't plan
your menu and list like a week in
advance or more you might be out of luck.
Also this tends to entail, you know,
having another human shop for your
groceries, bag them, and then either you
pick them up at the store, having paid
online, or they safe drop them at your
door. And the benefit of this is that you
don't have to go into the grocery store
which is particularly important if you
yourself are sick so that you don't
infect others. But what if your shopper
was unknowingly sick? Are there any extra
precautions that you should be taking in
this case? This is where you may want to
employ some extra disinfectant and food
safety precautions which I'm gonna be
talking more about in a lot more detail
in just a moment. Now let's talk about
the risk when it comes to restaurant
takeout and food delivery. While many of
us are fortunate enough to work from
home or take a leave of absence from
work to really limit our exposure to the
outside world, food service workers still
have to get up and go to work every day
to provide us access to takeout and
delivery services. However there have been
a lot of concerns raised around the
safety and risks of ordering takeout and
food delivery. I mean what if a delivery
driver has coronavirus and touches my
meal? What if the line cook has COVID-19
and is preparing my food? Well at
this moment, and this is changing rapidly
by the day, we don't have current
research to suggest that takeout or
drive-through meals are a high risk for
transmitting coronavirus. It's
obviously way safer than eating in a
restaurant, which none of us can do right
now anyways because they've all been
mandated to close. But takeout and food
delivery limits the amount of social
contact and thereby makes it easier to
maintain social distance from other
individuals potentially infected with
the virus.
Many delivery services now also have
implemented practices that limit the
amount of contact one person might have
with a delivery person in order to
further reduce the risk. So for example
many online ordering services, like uber
eats, have implemented contactless
deliveries allowing the option to leave
deliveries at the door.
Other drive-thru and takeout services
have also gone completely cashless and
use touch free or card only transactions.
But as we've already discussed, current
research does suggest that the risk of
infection from touching food or
packaging that has been exposed to the
virus is relatively low. Having said that,
if you have any concerns about, you know
the early state of this research and
wants to take some extra precautions to
further minimize the risk of possible
infection, you can follow these steps.
When ordering food through takeout or
food delivery. Number one, handle takeout
and delivery packages with gloves.
Number two, remove the food from the
packaging. Number three, immediately
dispose of the food packaging. Four,
transfer the food using tongs or spoons
to a clean plate or container. Five,
safely dispose of the gloves. Six wash
your hands with soap and water for 20
seconds before eating. And seven, reheat
your food if possible, which I'll talk a
little bit more about in a moment but
you can also avoid kind of raw salad bar
types of food that can't be cooked and
may be sitting out in the open where
others can potentially sneeze or cough
on them. Okay so you now know the risk is
relatively low especially for delivery
and take-out options, but how can we
sterilize packages and food to further
reduce our risk. Now current evidence
suggests that the best way to disinfect
surfaces, including any food boxes
bottles and cans is to use either soap
and water,
ideally a dish detergent. Diluted
household bleach solutions. Alcohol solutions with at least 70% alcohol
or store-bought disinfectant wipes. As
for our foods, the exact temperatures and
times for disinfecting foods that may
have come in contact with COVID 19 is
still being researched. However,
scientists suggests that a temperature of
149 Fahrenheit or 65 Celsius for at
least 3 minutes is sufficient. Other
heating methods to kill viruses and
bacteria from food include heating
liquids like soups, stews, and sauces to a
brief simmer and making sure to stir
frequently so that they're heated evenly
throughout. Or you can microwave food
until piping hot. For most microwaves
this is usually about 90 seconds on high
heat. So what does that look like for
food that you bring into the house? Again
the current research suggests that food
and food packaging is likely very low
risk but here are some precautions that
you can maybe take to make sure
everything is fully safe to eat.
Number one, wash any produce under cool
running water with a vegetable brush
making sure to regularly clean the brush
with soap and water. To wipe down any
cardboard packages with an alcohol
solution of 70% alcohol or higher, a
diluted bleach solution, or disinfectant
wipes. Number three, cook anything that
you can't wash thoroughly to at least
149 Fahrenheit for at least 3 minutes.
Four, reheat any prepared foods for 90
seconds on high in the microwave. Five,
purchase any raw produce when you can in
a sealed package like bag or box salad
greens rather than loose, and be sure to
disinfect the packaging before storing.
The bottom line is that there is a
relatively low risk of contracting the
virus from the food supply or through
takeout or delivery services. Ultimately,
your risk of infection of COVID 19 is
dependent on your interaction and
proximity to individuals who may be
potentially infected with the virus. That
is why social distancing is so important
and should be considered when making
food decisions. A good rule of thumb is
to always consider the ways that you can
minimize the amount of touch points with
other people as this is the best way to
reduce your risk of exposure to the
virus. From this perspective, food
delivery, whether it's delivery of
prepared foods or grocery delivery would
have the least amount of risk
as you're only making contact with one
person. You can also specify no contact
rules with your order by having the
delivery person just drop off the food
at your door and you may have the option
to pay online to avoid paying at the
door as well. Though still considered
relatively low risk picking up takeout
orders or groceries would have a higher
amount of risk in comparison to delivery
as there are just more touch points
involved. Touch points may include things
like driving or taking public transit,
opening doors, exposure to crowded
environments, waiting in line, interacting
with food service workers or cashiers,
and making a payment. Even though the
current early research we have does not
suggest that food is a high risk
transporter of the virus, you can always
take some of these extra precautions
with food that you bring into the house
to further minimize your risk. Now I hope
that you can all use this information to
make mindful decisions and that they
bring you a sense of control rather than
more anxiety about food. There is already
so much anxiety around food which I'm going to be
talking about in another video very soon
but until then I would love to hear how
you guys are all doing. So leave me a
comment below, like this video, subscribe
let me know if you'd like to see more
COVID 19 videos or more of my regular
types of videos or like a mix of the
both. I am fully open and I'm gonna try
to keep up with the demand despite this
more challenging setup for me. Ok folks
that is all for me today. Take care and
chat soon, bye!